today's question comes from bradley in
wisconsin and bradley writes
last year my wife and i became involved
in a multi-level marketing business
since then i find i found out how
deceptive this company is in their
business practices
i don't want to waste any more money on
these products but my wife is so
brainwashed that i don't know if she
will exit this fake
dream it may come down to her choosing
this business
over me and our children what should i
do
first thing brother take a breath
relax there's way more going on here
than
multi-level marketing
anthony uh you're speechless man
i i don't i don't know what to say here
bro um and here's why i
i don't i don't know i don't know too
much information to say i mean that's a
heavy statement
say that your wife would choose this
this multi-level um
marketing company uh over you like
i would need some more information to
see why does he feel that way because i
agree with you
if your wife is going to choose an mlm
over you and your
children way bigger problems this is not
about the mlm
it's about something else that the mlm
is just covering
um and so uh i would suggest that this
guy gives your show a call
because you we need some more we need
some more questions
just with what we've got here bradley
what should you do
i don't even know i don't even like the
way you're talking about your wife what
you should do right now bradley is go
find someone to talk to
yeah i agree go find a professional to
talk to and say
i'm about to leave take my kids go to
war over my kids because my wife
wants to i don't know sell avon or
tupperware or whatever the mlm business
is
mary kay she wants to to to do um
a stay-at-home business and i'm out and
i want to take our kids away
there's something way bigger going on
here bradley but you ever find yourself
up against a line here that says i'm
about to be out of here stop which
before you jump go go talk to somebody
yeah go talk to somebody
and for the listeners i want to make
sure we're clear because you named you
named a couple we're not
calling those oh i'm just saying those
are scams no no no no no because i
i there are some solid mlm companies out
there that
that i think are good but there are
there are a lot of them out there that
are that are bad
and i've had the opportunity to speak at
some of them um
but um i do agree that some of them do
brainwash
do do mislead but then there are several
of them out there
that are good and if if you're willing
to put in the work and
good stuff for people yeah you can
really do it um you know i have family
that does
you know like avon and mary kay and so
um
you know i respect them but then there's
some out there that lord jesus
i run from them i don't know enough
about him
yeah yeah i feel you i feel you now i
just want to make sure that that we said
that because i don't want someone to
think oh he just said no
no no no no no i'm not counting on
anybody i'm trying to more put
look at get bradley to look in the
mirror yeah if you're going to walk out
on your family
over your wife's participation in a work
from home business
yeah there's something bigger going on
much bigger i
they need therapy they need help um and
and and correct me if i'm wrong john is
this even a conversation that they
should start by themselves or should
they literally go to counseling
and then walk through the the honesty
and transparency with
a third party guiding them through this
journey or should they try it
on their own so so this is a good
breakdown for the listener when i look
at something like this
and i see language like i found out how
deceptive
i don't want to waste she's going to
exit this fake dream
right he's angry yep he's angry
and the last thing a marriage or a
friendship
or a boss an employee they need is
someone to go try to have a relationship
conversation when they're pissed off
right yep so what i want him to do is go
sit with somebody
by himself by himself okay anger's good
anger is not a bad thing anger just
points you in the direction of something
you care about yeah it's good yeah right
yeah but when it changes your language
when it makes you get short of breath
when it makes you get ragey and reggie
is anger trapped right so when it makes
you start
wanting to start having fantasies about
grabbing your kids and getting out of
here
you need to go sit down with somebody
learn how to exhale
and then have a hard conversation with
with your wife you know that's that's
all good man
let's say right there let's talk about
the importance of
therapy bro so i see a therapist
you know um uh doing what we do
um being on stages being on platforms
being in front of
the world as a public figure
i there are some days that i get
frustrated
there are some days that i i emotionally
and mentally break down there are some
days that i feel like just giving up i'm
gonna be i'm gonna keep it a stack
and i what you just said is i started
saying
certain words and immediately
uh one of my friends said you you're not
sick
but if you don't get help you will
become mentally sick
and i would definitely say and i'm
curious for your thoughts
because you promote mental uh mental
therapy and just seeing a therapist on
your show
when i started going to see a therapist
and i was 100
honest with the therapist i became a
better man
i thought better i thought clearer i
started
owning some of my thought processes when
someone offended me oh
america let me tell you the truth let me
tell you the truth when someone offended
me
it wasn't that they offended me it's a
it was i was insecure about something
and so my insecurity made what they said
offensive to me
to cover up the truth that i was
insecure about something
and so for me when i see a therapist now
man
uh she is walking me through the process
to okay wait why does this offend you
let's let's identify why did this offend
you
why did you feel this way and john the
truth is bro
incredibly if i'm i'm i'm wrong and tell
me if you see this in your space
50 of the times when i'm hurt i'm
offended
was not because of the individual it was
because of something deep down inside of
me
that i that i need to resolve oh i think
i
appreciate your vulnerability there man
i think it's way higher than 50 percent
oh you think so way higher yeah because
at the end of the day
i give permission
to people to hurt me oh right
people can frustrate me dave can take
away my livelihood right he's my boss
his name's on my paycheck he can take
away my livelihood
right the guy driving in front of me can
frustrate me
somebody on twitter or facebook could
say something that's egregious and evil
and wrong and it can make me mad
but i give permission for somebody to
hurt me
and the smaller i can make that group
the lighter i can walk through life the
less i walk through so
charged and fire up so i actually went
through an exercise back in grad school
where you pick who are you going to get
permission in your life to hurt you
and it should be about four or five
people and here's what happened
i love my parents yeah yeah i took them
out
i had this little imaginary box are you
serious so my dad is allowed to give me
advice
he's allowed to help me with things give
me his opinion but he does i have
i've don't give him permission to hurt
my feelings so good but my wife she does
and here's the thing i told her what
about your kids absolutely not
you know why because they're nine
they're 11.
they're six if a six-year-old hey the
other day my six-year-old told me
uh she's yeah she's five she said hey
daddy
i love mommy more than you and i smiled
at her and said
i'm so glad you love mommy isn't she
great and then i started to walk away
and she realized she didn't get me she
goes
and i love hank my 11 year old son more
than you
and i said he is a really remarkable
young man i'm glad you love him and then
she went for the jugular she said
and i love stella more than you that's
our dog
[Laughter]
here's the thing i'm not going to give
my hurt over to a child
i've got a couple of friends that have
walked with me for years and years
i called them and said you guys got
permission use it wisely and they do
and then i'm able to walk through life a
little freer so good that makes sense so
good man
i get to choose who gets in there and
starts firing away